hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well the precepts of
the natural are practical reasons first
principles of demonstrations are
inspected they're self-evident
principles now that doesn't mean that we
all are aware of them all the time but
there are things you know that are very
general you cover a lot of situations
speculative reason it would be things
like the whole is greater than the parts
I mean does anybody need that prove to
them you know house is more than the
door you all get that right that that's
self-evident when we get to particular
examples it starts to get a little bit
sticky sometimes there we're moving from
the general to the particular then I've
so that practical reason works that way
too
there's certainly less any rules or
commands or ideas that are so
fundamental so basic and what do you
think I'm a little self-conscious but
there you know there are sometimes easy
to deviate so he says a certain order is
to be find those things that are
personally what do we do after ahead
what do we take in universally well
everything that you're looking at has
being its real existence so the notion
of this is included in all things
whatever a person pretends he says so as
being is the first thing that falls
under the apprehension so good is the
first thing that falls into the
apprehension of your practical reason
good is the broadest category there's a
lot of different ways in which things
can be good within that a lot this
semester
right so the practical reason is
directed to actions of doing things to
what you ought to do and it's directed
towards events so the first principle of
practical reason he says is good as that
is all things seek after the first
precept of the natural law good is
pursued
that's pretty pretty junk that covers an
awful lot of ground that doesn't give
you an awful lot of concrete guidance
and things does it that's that's
something that builds into the fabric of
your thinking that can be turned off
though you know when somebody actually
chooses to do something and they say I
know this is wrong but I want to do it
because I wanted you know I want to do
what's wrong they would be actually
going against this the highest principle
perhaps for reason kind of tough to do
usually when somebody does something
like that they're really seeking someone
I'm good
I'd like to do this because I like
screwing people over well that he likes
screwing people over and that's what
we're doing is good probably from now
this is a it's almost may have used this
example before anybody know Google's
don't be now does that tell you an awful
lot don't be
the trouble becomes how do you define it
there may be some paradoxes of it all
depends on how you define the terms
doesn't it and when it comes to good and
evil it's really a matter of
specification so we need something a bit
more concrete than that
so let's Thomas says okay well let's
look now then not just at being as a
whole let's look at human beings what
are our different levels what are the
different dimensions of human reading
and he says all those things to which
man
the natural inclination we're naturally
apprehended by reason as being good in
some way and consequently as objects
that pursue their contraries is evil and
objects of avoidance what is it that
we're naturally inclined to well let's
start with the broadest thing what do we
share in common with with all of their
beings says there's first of all an
inclination to good in accordance with
the nature which you and I have
important in common with all other
substance what is it that all beings
trying to do you science we filter and
enjoy not everything necessarily enjoys
but that is no complaints enjoy things
they enjoy them in a very different way
than we do but let's think about dance
what do plants what do they do it
survive is that what you get yes okay
all things attempt to continue all
things like he says desire or see the
preservation of their own being
according to their nature so you know
the nature of this iPhone is just a
piece of technology but doesn't report
when something gets screwed up on it you
know I mean that's not much of a
inclination you know this with a sense
this actually does hold together as an
object plastic actually turns out this
truck you know generally stays together
until I have more plants more complex
things react to their environment turn
towards the Sun the source of you know
nourishment they can't move from place
to place or make some kind of multiple
animals move from place to place
most animals replaced a place they tried
to continue in being don't we do that -
don't be able to do a lot of things for
the sake of survival what else now
looking to hire what the animals do
plants do this - certainly I phones
don't do it
what do they do
yeah
very good
plants due to this production
some flowers plants like jerking off on
flowers I know they're actually
particular part something you're
actually a particular part yeah you know
pedals are actually adapt to these yeah
other animals reproduce you know some of
those reproduce are kind of weird made
with earthworms in guests who change
their their sacks and basically there's
no bump against each other you know
insects do all sorts of kind of kind of
interesting things some of them you know
only exist for the purpose of mating
like you know these male bees in the
hive the only purpose they Adam is to
mate with the Queen then after that then
kick him out and maybe you seem to be
okay with it you know because that's
their their inclination one of the
swimmy animals do that goes beyond just
making babies
so like taking care of their babies or
whatever it is man yeah now let me go
all business baby alligators apparently
mother alligator will the mammals are
are pretty no why do I need you to make
no oh because it's a way of neutrals
continue to take care of their babies
but how can you get up or caregivers
yeah boy dolphins like they don't it's
not just the parents yeah like their
whole pack I guess or whatever you call
gotta see how zombies travel it's
interesting like how they all
participate yeah yeah that's what fish
are referred to probably yeah you know I
mean maybe Susan with some haters too I
mean one thing about chimpanzees they
are pretty brutal creatures
we need ones we've got a completely
backwards which of hands is the ones who
kill each other
but it will take care of others young
and you know it's really interesting if
you look at between solutions the
animals will actually sometimes adopt
babies not even other species yeah I saw
that everyone's waiting
yeah you know what's interesting
yes a lot of these animals it turns out
that their instincts are a little bit
less hardwired and more needing things
to happen in their environment than the
big one you know one of the shows that I
used to watch my daughter that I really
enjoyed was they do these animal rescues
these these rhinos and elephants and the
animals like the wild animals has lost
their their mothers and
sort of path with pride like that and
they bring them into an enclosure and
then quite often they pair them up with
another animal with different species
who is also a young and eventually they
didn't start to play together
so you think elephants will only play
another in elements but actually
elephants will play with minors or will
play with you know things like they will
live a bond with each other they're
actually been cases with older animals
having pets at least you know gorillas
kind of kittens now that's not happening
a while right but but if they do this
with researchers and so it brings up
something within them something that
again natural laws of matter
inclinations and we are not unique in
yeah sorry to put this out there I don't
know if anybody here has seen there's
this guy that raised lion cubs from one
day were young oh yeah they're now like
a full-grown male alive yeah they play
around with them and they treat him like
he's the leader of the pack
hey guy and there's that that big - of
that guy who goes to Africa
yeah and everyone's thinking that the
Lions going to eat him they said that
Lions don't remember people who don't
you know don't go out there because
we're not going to be responsible and
sure enough he goes out of there and you
see on the video the lion killing
creeping up but he's got that again part
of a higher animal nature is this
bonding that takes place that's just not
just to do it instant
that develops sort of thing that talks
about is an inclination to the good
according to the nature reason what
makes us distinctively human together
and each one of those takes a fairly
determinant shape so you know one of the
you want to make this a little bit more
specific to continue in being what can
we derive from that the inclination or
the precept is that what blocks that
half along whatever is a meaning warning
obstacles
so the natural law says that you should
respect life humanely
in particular because that that is our
kind
it doesn't necessarily single just
through all the other animals do
whatever you want to them Thomas isn't
saying yeah but he is saying there's
something instinctive levels so when you
see somebody you know threatening
another person and you feel that that's
wrong that's because there's an
inclination that was coming from you
know are being woven into us when you
want to help somebody who is sick
that's warding off whatever is an
obstacle to human life whatever is the
means of preserving human life what do
we need to preserve our lives what are
our basic needs food and shelter
providing other people food and shelter
not just ourselves notice that that this
isn't just about our own
self-preservation this is about the
preservation of other beings providing
other people with food and shelter when
they don't happen is fulfilling the
natural law depriving them of food or
shelter would be against it
so going burning somebody's house down
it's not just a bad thing because you
know their property it's a bad thing
because you actually took away their
shelter as they sometimes say taking
food out of my children's mouths if
somebody actually is doing that by you
know whatever they're doing in the
workplace to somebody else then they're
violating the natural law
you know there's certain basic needs
certain basic things that the natural
law says
do you think of any others food shelter
medical care perhaps I was gonna say
ergo we thought you said do it on our
own I think what is yeah I think that's
certain environmental thing access to
water could be a matter of the natural
law as well clean air water you know
it's a big initiative here being
discussed in New York because the
fracking are they meant to allow these
chemicals to be driven underground to to
bring down other things which make up
the water supply that could be thought
of in terms of the natural let's move on
to the next one we have we have
reproduction and raising young so you
know what does the banjo law actually
tell us that we ought to do we ought to
in fact have sexual intercourse
otherwise the species dies out right we
have a natural instinct towards that
yeah and the natural law which also
should be exercised in certain ways you
know for instance sort of radical
promiscuity screwing anything that most
would not be you know fulfilling that
instinct in and away in accordance with
reason I mean just just think you know
today how these things could go along
with that
back in Thomas's time they did have
syphilis you know other B's syphilis is
for her if ik by it's all sex
yeah it's not as common some of the
other
to worry about as well right what are
some of the other things you'd have to
worry about go out and follow your
sexual instinct whatever it happens to
be well how could that go wrong yeah
yeah you know if you're going to have
children and you should actually like be
prepared to take care of them what else
what Wales is a bad idea to sleep with
anybody who will possibly because what
it's just gross well you have you know
if you set your bar very long but it's
probably to do that a pleasure
okay so let's say you actually gather
per visitor there sleep with anybody who
will sleep with you you don't find gross
what else
okay now again your your you look
properly functioning Faculty of reason
that you're actually listening it's you
know recognizing certain inclinations
there are certain goods that you would
deprive yourself of and also other
people by just indulging your sexual
appetite industry raising children
what does raising children and well I
mean that's something to think about
this too because I mean just showing up
putting food on the table to all right
responsibilities something some people
like to do how so that's a big one yeah
I mean if you're actually telling your
kids don't beat up the other kids take
their lunch money
you're not facilities in national water
you're not raising their kids well
actually if you don't have teachers then
you have to teach your kids and we can
actually farm out a lot of this child
beers and stuff to teachers
if you're gonna do that you should
probably actually check them out I think
these days if you want to get to the
nitty-gritty of this the natural law
would probably say you should you should
have a good idea what those in charge of
your kids are actually doing it's the
kids are ultimately your responsibility
what's good to do is it enough justice
really put up the guardrails yeah
nervous yeah you mean rude that's
important too what else should you get a
children yeah
what's I think that's that it yes yes
it's yours who don't love their children
then it's tough to love kids sometimes
actually quite frankly you know it takes
work sometimes parents who don't love
their children are actually in Thomas's
of you violating the natural law and if
they thought about this if reason was
functioning well with them they could
figure out hey I'm screwing up I need to
fix this I need to do things differently
some type of carrots cameras for moments
about if you're getting the wrong
messages from society if your passions
are disordered it's going to be much
harder to love your children and as you
watch the when we complete even higher
level the distinctively human life I
don't even say this is a distinction
being - we love our children that way as
the horses don't if we get to the higher
level where it has to do with reason he
says there is in every person in the
pretty that's a reason and this is the
act of corn conversion so we should in
fact actually cultivate the virtues if
we speak of virtuous acts then those are
going to involve a lot of different
applications of Reason what else do we
have a natural inclination to do to
other things that's really important to
other things that are really distinctive
to us human beings one is to live in
society now we talked about this before
other animals do have somewhat of a
social organization they don't debate it
out dogs don't say should we have a
dictatorship or a democracy you know
what sort of rules should we make for
this path they just sort of you know do
things B's you know do incredibly the
trust it's actually answering they're
working twice but ants don't sit down
and say is our society on the right
track or not the other thing that Thomas
says does where I believe Thomas thinks
that that's part of the natural law
that's something distinctive to us and
there again you know we're moving into
this very ideological dimension so I
think that's a good place to to stop